Daniel: All right.
Greetings, Takuya.
Takuya: Hi.
Daniel: You can mute the live stream or
turn off the other live stream, but yeah,
thank you for joining.
Takuya: Yes, thank you for inviting thank
you for it.
Yeah, it.
Daniel: Well, we have a little bit 35 or
38 minutes, so it would be awesome to
have your presentation.
Takuya: Great.
So the moment well, can you see my.
Daniel: I saw PowerPoint.
Takuya: Okay.
Can you see my screen?
Daniel: Perfect.
Takuya: Okay.
So shall we start?
Daniel: Yes.
Thank you.
Takuya: Then.
Thank you for organizing this wonderful
symposium.
Today I'd like to talk about relationship
between canonical neural network and
active inference and possible extension
for modeling social and shared
intelligence using canonical neural
network.
So let's start.
As you know, the free energy principle is
proposed by Karl Friston that states that
perception, learning and action of all
biological organisms are determined to
minimize variational free energy as a
tractable proxy for surprise minimization.
.
And by this process organism can perform
parational BJ inference or external
mineral state.
And this can't even just show one example
typical set up under the free energy
principle active inference.
Here there is a hidden state in the
external world and only a part of this
state can be observable.
For our agent, this doc and this
transformation is done by genetic model
parameterized by theta and to infer the
hidden state, agent need to reconstruct
the copy of the external state called
posterior relief.
And this optimization is done by
minimizing variational free energy.
And parameter is also optimized by
minimizing free energy to obtain an apt
generative model to represent this
relationship.
An interesting aspect of the free energy
principle active inference is its
application to the optimization of action.
.
Here our agent have some preference prior
c and to obtain this observation in the
future, agent may select the action that
minimize the expected free energy in the
future to obtain the most predictable
outcome.
And finally, by selecting actions that
minimize the expect frequency, it can
obtain the feed.
So, this is a typical setup under active
inference.
But question is what is the neural
neurosurge that can implement this
process?
So that is our interest and to address
this issue we propose theory as follows.
Here we consider that external world is
parameterized characterized by a set of
the variables like this here, this is a
posterior expectation and the S indicates
the hidden state in the external world.
Delta indicate the action of the agent or
decision and the theta indicate a
parameter and lambda is a hyperparameter.
.
So those set of parameters or variables
characterize a generative model and free
energy variational.
Free energy is defined as a function of
the sequence of observation and external
state and its minimization indicates the
variational Bayesian inference.
Similarly, we consider a dynamics of
neural network and we consider that
dynamics is characterized by a set of
those variables.
Here x indicates the neuroactivity firing
rate at middle raya neurons and y
indicate neuroactivity of output raya
neurons and W here is a synaptic weight
and phi is any other free parameter that
characterize neural network.
And we consider that neural network
dynamics is characterized by minimization
of some cost function l.
This is a function of the O and Phi
internal state of neural network and its
minimization indicates the generation of
neural network dynamics including both
activity and plasticity.
And our theory indicates equivalence
between those two functions.
Meaning that for any neural network that
minimize some cost function error, there
is a generative model that satisfy if we
call error.
Which means that the recapturation of
external dynamics is an inherent feature
of any neural system that follow such
dynamics.
So this is an interesting prediction but
too abstract.
So I would like to introduce some
analytically tractable example to
understand this relationship formally.
So first we consider a very simple
architecture.
This is represented by POMDP without any
state transition.
So hidden state s is simply generated by
priya distribution D and it is a binary
state.
But we consider a vector of binary state,
so it is a factory of structure and
observation is also a binary vector and
the transformation from S to O is
characterized by categorical distribution
using likelihood of matrix A and
variational Bayesian inference indicates
the inversion of this generative process
like this.
So by solving the appropriate frequency
functional we obtain those posterior
brief that is optimal in the Bayesian
sense.
On the other hand, for neural network we
consider such structure here upper part
indicates the generation of signal in the
external world and the neural network
comprises only single layer.
Here activity of output layer are
generated by weighted sum of sensory
input O weighted by synaptic matrix W.
And we then characterize this neural
network in the next slide.
So to model neural network or neuron, we
start from considering hodgeken hacksray
equation which comprises four
differential equation and this is a very
complicated non linear equation although
it is barely possible.
So we consider some reduction of these
equations.
So a typical reduction method is like
this for example, m here is much faster
than other variables so this can be
repressed with its fixed point or it is
known that h and minus one sorry, it is
known that h and one minus SN have
similar dynamics.
So we can consider a new effective
variable U to characterize those two
variables and then we obtain 2D hoskin
hacks ray equation like this.
So this is a famous cross of neural
network model which includes the well
known Fitzfuel Nagamo model or other
continuous neural network model and we
modify those model to derive canonical
neural model.
So this is a definition of canonical
neural network model.
Here leak current is characterized by
imbass sigmoid function instead of cubic
function which is adopted in the Fitzfuel
Nagmo model.
And we also consider connection synaptic
connection and this part indicates
synaptic input from sensory layer through
weight matrices and 1 may consider that W
one indicate excitatory synapse and W
zero indicate inhibitory synapse and the
threshold are adaptive thresholds that
are function of W one and W zero.
Interestingly, when we consider a fixed
point of this differential equation we
obtain well known red coding model with
the Sigmoidal activation function.
Which means that we can say that in some
sense this canonical neural network
network model is approximation of Hodgkin
hatt's ray equation and its approximation
level is, in some sense between the
realistic model and the most simplified
red coding model.
So we basically consider this type of
neural network model and in the next
slide we consider what is the plausible
cost function for this neural network
model.
So again we write the same equation for
canonical neural network model which
represents the activity of neurons vector
of neurons and we consider cost function
for this differential equation which can
be obtained by simply calculating the
integral of right hand side of this
equation and get this type of cost
function for neural network.
This is biologically plausible cost
function in the sense that its derivative
derived neural network activity which has
a certain biological plausibility.
Moreover, if we consider derivative of
this cost function with respect to
synaptic weight W, we obtain a
conventional synaptic plasticity rule
which follows Hebian law.
On the other hand, for Bayesian inference
we first define generality model like the
previous slide and we then derive
variational free energy for given genetic
model.
So this variation of free energy is
derived from the Pom DP model in the
previous slide and its minimization
indicates the Beijing inference and
running.
So we found formal correspondences
between component of those two cost
functions like this.
So this broke vector formally correspond
to this Brock vector that represent a
posterior expectation and this logarithm
correspond to this logarithm and actually
this a matrix can be represented as the
broke matrix like this and its dot
product correspond to this computation.
And finally, this phi naturally
correspond to this log d logo state prior.
.
Which means that because the cost
function are same, its derivative
provides its derivative provides sorry.
Because the cost function are formally
equivalent, its derivative sorry.
It's a result of derivative also
corresponding each other.
Which means that for any neural activity
equation in this form, there is a
corresponding Bayesian inference equation.
.
This is an equation that compute the
posterior belief of the hidden state and
this synaptic practice equation formally
correspond to learning or parameter of
genetic model.
And moreover, by establishing this
relationship we can consider the reverse
engineering of the generality model from
empirical data here this schematic
summarize our approach to reverse
engineer generative model and we first
record the neural activity and assign the
canonical neural network to explain this
obtained data.
And by computing the integral we obtained
a cost function for this canonical
network.
And by the mathematical equivalence we
established, we can automatically
identify genetic model and variational
free energy that correspond to this
neural network architecture.
So interestingly, this is a Bayesian
agent which is a kind of artificial
intelligence.
But importantly, this artificial
intelligence is formally derived from
empirical data.
So we can say that this agent is
biomimetic artificial intelligence that
follow the free energy principle and then
its derivative with respect to parameter
posterior derived synaptic plastic
algorithms that follow the free energy
minimization and its time integral can
predict the running process of original
neural network data.
Which means that if the frequency
principle is correct, then this
prediction should work, should work and
should be able to predict the result of
this neural neta without referencing to
the data itself.
So our strategy is in summary, our
strategy is that we reconstruct
generative model only from the initial
data, like initial data before running
and then predict the running process or
running curve that this neural system
should follow by using the frequency
principle and compare or examine whether
this prediction is correct by comparing
actual data after running and the
prediction by the free energy principle.
And if this prediction is correct, then
it indicates the predictive validity of
the free energy principle under setup
considered.
So we apply this strategy to the in vitro
neural network.
So here, this in vitro neural network are
stimulated using the POMDP generative
process defined in the previous slide.
So there are two hidden sources that are
binary signals and they are mixed to
generate 32 sensory stimuli.
Those are also binary.
And this is an overview of experiment by
stimulating in vitro neurons they
generate spiking response and those rhyme
indicate a high density spiking response.
.
So we observed that in some neuron the
response specificity is so we found that
for some neuron response was high to
source one signal compared to source two
signal.
And if we see the transition of those
neurons, we found that although we
removed the offset at the first session
to set those activities zero, but we see
that those neuron self organized to
respond high when source one is one, but
those neurons response low level when the
source one is zero.
So which means that those neurons
activity, those neurons response was
consistent with our theoretical
prediction that neuroactivity cell
organized to encode the posterior
expectation of healing state.
And we also found that some other group
of neuron responds preferentially to
source two but not to source one.
So then we ask okay, then we found that
posterior expectation is encoded by
neuroactivity and the next question is
about other neuronal substrate and we
then ask if the prior brief about hidden
state is effectively equal to the firing
threshold of neural activity model,
neural network model.
So if the theory is correct, this
correspondence should exist.
To check this, we first simulated a
Bayern agent and when we varied the PRI
of the Bayesian agent, the inference was
attenuated as I expected.
And we found that when we buried the
excitatory level of in vitro neural
network by using the pharmacological
manipulation.
We also found that the attenuation of
inference which is consistent with our
theoretical prediction that firing
threshold encode prior belief or the
hidden state.
And next we consider whether the
scientific plasticity followed the free
energy principle by asking whether free
energy principle can predict the
qualitative self organization of a
subsequent neural data.
So here we model neural network like this,
, there are two ensemble neurons that
encode source one and source two.
And we first compute the effective
synaptic weight of those networks using a
conventional connection strength
estimation approach and plot those
synaptic weights on the landscape of
theoretically computed free energy.
So this is a trajectory of empirically
estimated synaptic weights effective sign
optic connectivity and as predicted,
those changes reduce the free energy.
And here we computed this theoretically
predicted free energy landscape only
using the past ten sessions data.
So that this indicates that indicates
some prediction of the self organization.
.
And for more explicit prediction, we then
simulated neuroactivity and plasticity
using green as a principle.
Here the brighter color indicates the
prediction of data without reference to
activity data.
So those lines exactly follow this free
energy gradient.
And we found that this predicted
trajectory is tightly correlated with
this empirically estimated effective
synaptic weights.
And LR rate is like this.
So it indicates that frequency principle
can quantitatively predict the
circumstance in this setup, so it
indicates some predictive validity of the
free energy principle under this setup.
And then we also consider the modeling of
the neuromodulation using active
inference.
It is well known that synaptic process is
modified by various factors like Dopamine,
, northern adrenaline, acetylcholine,
serotonin, so on.
And one interesting property of those
moderation is that even though Dopamine
was added after associative plasticity
was established, it can change the result
of plasticity in a post hoc or
restorespective manner, so it implies
some association to the reward and past
decisions.
So we model this process using canonical
neural network.
So here we model the post hoc modulation
of HEBM plasticity using this type of
plasticity equation and we also consider
the recurrent neural network structure
and output layer for this network.
And we consider that modulation occur at
this connectivity layer.
And then we found cost function that can
derive those differential equations and
then found corresponding variational free
energy and genetic model which means that
this sort of neural network activity
including moderation of sinus plasticity
exactly follow the free energy principle
under some type of homodp generative
model.
And by using this, we show that this
biologically plausible neural network
model with moderation of heavy and
plasticity can solve some sort of delayed
reward task like maze task.
And then finally we would like to discuss
a possible extension to this framework to
the modeling social intelligence.
So, to infer our con specifics, we need
to select an appropriate generality model
for our partners, depending on our
partners.
So this can be done by Beijing model
selection scheme and we previously
proposed a model that can predict the
multiple biosomes using one big genetic
model that comprises multiple genetic
models.
And this movie shows prediction of
prediction of songs.
So like this, this model nicely
identified which genetic model is the
best to explain a given sensory input.
And this process indicates and the model
can correctly infer the appropriate model
and then imitate the song by its own
action.
So, although in the previous work we didn'
't discuss a detailed neural neural
substrate for this mixture generative
model, we now be able to consider the
corresponding circuit architecture.
For example, if we consider the
moderation of neural module by
neuromodulator like Dopamine, it act as
an attentional filter.
And this attentional filter can be
explained by three factor Hebian running
rule introduced in the previous slide.
So again, this modulation works as the
post hoc moderation plasticity.
And this modulation can optimize each
model to represent one generative model,
one generate one song in a mutually
independent manner.
So, through this process, it is possible
to learn multiple generative model in a
vertically plausible manner.
So, in summary, we found that the
dynamics of kinetic neural network that
minimize a cost function can be read as
minimization of variational free energy.
It indicates free energy principle is an
apt explanation for this type of neural
network.
And we also validate this prediction
using some in vitro setup by showing that
free energy principle can quantitatively
predict the self organization of
subsequent plasticity only using the
initial data.
And as the modeling, we can extend those
canonical network modeling to the action
generation as a planning via the delayed
moderation of heavy emperor's DST.
And finally, we discuss possibility to
extend this canonical model to modeling
the social or shared intelligence ah to
interact with multiple partners.
So, that's all of my talk.
Thank you for listening.
This is Acknowledgment.
Our collaborator and fundings and our
unit are now recruiting postdoc
researchers.
So if you're interested, please check.
Daniel: Awesome.
Thank you for the presentation, Takuya.
I'll just ask a few quick questions from
the live chat and a few other things that
come up.
So Dave says Takuya used the phrase after
plasticity was established.
Was his group able to modify e g increase
plasticity?
Or is he saying merely that it was shown
that there is plasticity?
Takuya: Yeah, I'm not sure if I
understand correctly your question, but
those groups show that Dopamine adding
Dopamine after 2 seconds after the
association occurred can change the
magnitude of plasticity.
So without how to say if Dopamine
addition was before this association,
then plasticity level is low.
But after Dopamine addition after
association can change this level can
increase the plasticity like this or like
this which indicates the post hook
moderation.
Cool.
Daniel: I think that answers it.
Well, what are you excited for?
Or what are your hopes or feelings on
where the active inference ecosystem is
at and where we're headed in the coming
months and years?
Takuya: Sorry again chris, just what are
you excited about?
Daniel: Other than your own research
directions?
What are you excited about in the active
inference ecosystem?
Takuya: Yeah.
So, of course, one direction is the
modeling of social interaction, which is
much rich architecture than the
interaction between the static
environment.
So if both agents run with each other,
then many interesting phenomena can be
observed.
So we are excited with modeling those
phenomena using biologically plausible
neural network model through this
equivalence.
Daniel: Awesome.
Any last comments?
Any other comments that you want to make,
,
Takuya?
Awesome.
Thanks again for the presentation.
And people should check out Live Stream
51, where you and I talked a few other
times and went into some of the details
on that work.
There's a lot there.
It's really exciting.
Takuya: Thank you.
Daniel: All right, thank you.
See you next time.
Takuya: See you next time.
Daniel: Bye.